[Music]
the entertainment world lost a
jack-of-all-trades last week Ricky J was
an oddball showman with an encyclopedic
knowledge of his craft and unmatched
skill in using his hands to fool the
eyes
it took him from a sideshow act to the
bright lights of Hollywood you be so
kind as to mention it for me Jack of
Diamonds out of the deck into my hand as
if propel a death in the hands of Ricky
Jay a deck of cards could come to life
here nine of clubs your six a diver Jay
who died last week was known as a
magician's magician whose tricks baffled
even the most experienced sleight of
hand artists a fixture on late-night
television Jay began performing in front
of audiences as a boy but his obsession
with magic ran far deeper Jay was known
as a foremost expert on the subject
writing several books on magic sideshow
entertainers con men and hustlers
throughout the ages fly yo me $6,000
that knowledge landed him work as a
technical consultant in Hollywood his
company built the wheelchair used in
Forrest Gump that had actor Gary
Sinise's legs he also found his way into
movies and television shows even law
enforcement was interested in his
ability to spot a cheat as he told 60
minutes in 2010 while getting one over
on Morley Safer
I would also beware of someone who will
rely heavily on an affiliation with an
investor group be it religious ethnic or
Geographic he was describing Madoff to a
tee I think these elements will make the
market ripe for any sort of pyramid or
Ponzi scam Ricky Jett and that is pure
Bernard Madoff
it's pure Bernie Madoff what can I tell
you another element of the con that I
actually made this page on Photoshop
last night
but his ability to defy reality with a
shift of the hands and a shuffle of the
deck is what made Ricky J an ace
entertainer Wow you know just an
extraordinary guy an experiment an
amazing magician too and and will became
a movie star an effect there's there's
something about magic that just brings
us all in yeah it really does we all
love to be tricked before